this sounds like a conservative message
I said what are you talking about right
she said well you know the conservative
message of how do you pay for things and
I said are you kidding me yeah I noticed
after that first debate when you were
getting googled and everybody was going
well who is this yeah is this but
suddenly some of the mainstream outlets
so like the BuzzFeed and HuffPo and the
rest of them they were trying to link
you to the all right and the trolls and
she's secretly being supported by
conservatives and all that now
me and the people that are doing the
online thing it's like we see this all
the time and you step out of anything
that sort of the the modern left doesn't
want you to do you're automatically the
bad guy but then when I saw it going
after you I was like yeah yeah I mean it
started before that to be honest it
started the very day that I announced my
candidacy for president
yeah and it's as if anything anteater or
which is your number one piece as if
that is conservative I mean that's what
they're trying to sell me yeah would you
a reporter asked me this question
literally just yesterday after the New
Hampshire Democratic convention she said
well you know you use talking about how
I've made it a central focus of my
campaign that we need to end these
wasteful counterproductive wars work to
end this new Cold War an arms race and
redirect our taxpayer dollars that we've
wasted for so long to the tune of six
trillion dollars since 9/11 alone
redirect those resources back here to
serve the needs of our people to take
care of the urgent concerns people out
whether it's health care infrastructure
education and and her point was well
this sounds like a conservative message
I said what are you talking about right
she said well you know the conservative
message of how do you pay for things and
I said are you kidding me yeah I said
I'll tell you what Americans across this
country are sick and tired of hearing
from politicians and from their
government that there's not enough money
to make sure that kids in Flint kids in
Newark kids in communities across this
country can't have clean water to drink
because the government can't make sure
that
infrastructure ensures clean water you
know they're sick and tired of hearing
that
you know levees are failing and there's
massive flooding in rural Iowa that's
ruining farms for their entire year of
crops and they're told well you know
what sorry there's just not enough money
to make sure that this infrastructure is
holding to keep you and your family safe
so this is not a conservative concern
this is an American concern and it is a
call to action to to change our
priorities bring about this sea change
this is why I'm running for president
right to bring the the leadership and
the conviction to stand up to the
foreign policy establishment the
military-industrial complex bringing the
experience that I have both as a soldier
as well as in Congress to shift our
priorities to stop this waste and bring
it back to that central focus of serving
the American people yeah well it's just
such a fascinating flip ya suddenly
anti-war yeah they want to sell it as
conservative I most people are actually
anti-war I mean I think most people
don't really want to go to ours that
being said is trump complicating the
issue for you particularly a little bit
because Trump at least from where I'm
sitting has not been pro war you may not
be happy with some of the some of the
things he's doing but you know he wants
to get us out of Afghanistan it doesn't
seem like we're gonna be nation-building
so that being the anti-war candidate is
a little trickier as opposed to if it
was if he was just more of a traditional
Republican maybe we're right right I
don't I don't I don't think it makes it
tricky at all Trump campaigned a lot on
this message of ending stupid Wars
bringing our troops home calling out
Saudi Arabia for being you know one of
the biggest supporters for terrorism
that they are the problem is after he
got into office after he got elected he
chose to surround himself with the very
same neocon war hawks that have been
pushing for more of these
counterproductive regime change wars for
a very long time people like john bolton
people he has now secretary Mike Pompeo
and I think if we we find ourselves in
the position that we're in where in fact
Trump hasn't carried through on the
promises that he made the rhetoric that
he was using during that camp
and that's where I find so many people
were coming to our town hall saying they
feel betrayed because of that because he
has not only not brought our troops home
and yes he's working on getting our
troops home from Afghanistan and that is
good for America I wish him success in
doing that they should have come home a
long time ago but we've got more troops
in Syria he and his administration has
pushed us very close to the brink of war
with Iran deploying more troops to Saudi
Arabia and to the region escalating
tensions there while even though he says
on television that he doesn't want to go
to war with Iran every one of his
actions has pushed us to that brink
where we sit today we're just a match
could like the whole thing on fire how
do you balance the rhetoric of saying
I'm against war without sort of tipping
to the enemy whoever it may be that
you're not a pushover that seems to be
one of the things that yeah because I
don't I don't say that I'm against I
mean nobody wants war trust me and as a
veteran I've seen the cost of war
firsthand but I'm very specific in
saying we need to end these wasteful
regime-change wars we've got to stop
being the world's police trying to go
around the world and you know pick off
which dictators we don't like and you
know keep and prop up the authoritarian
dictators that that we do like as we've
seen happen throughout our country's
history and the wasteful regime change
wars maintain our national security by
having a ready and capable military and
continue to work to defeat those who
threaten the United States continue to
work to defeat terrorist threats like Al
Qaeda and like Isis and doing so in a
smart and effective way all right so I
want to do a whole bunch on on all the
issues we'll just hold on but I got to
just go backwards a little bit here
let's just talk about what's generally
happening with it with the DNC because I
think there's just a belief out there
whether it for Democrats Republicans it
doesn't matter that the DNC just strikes
people as deeply corrupt they they
basically screwed over Bernie last time
there's a feeling now that even with you
not being in the debate that it's just
unclear which polls are allowed to be
looked at and which aren't and how they
you know
accumulate all of them and look at the
numbers and all that do you think the
DNC is actively working against you do
you think it is corrupt do you think it
is in bed with one of the other
candidates or several of the other
candidates what is happening what's
clear is that this system lacks
transparency the whole process is
lacking transparency and that's the
change and that's the reform that I'm
calling for from the DNC in this because
if they're not transparent with their
process and you pointed out some of the
issues that are coming to light here is
you know well these small number of
polls are qualifying these other ones
are not why is that who are they
actually talking to how many people are
they talking to there are credible
accurate polls that they're choosing not
to recognize and questionable polls that
they are so the the the problem with all
of this and I speak as a strong Democrat
is that it it creates a lack of trust in
Democratic voters that the DNC is
actually working for their interest in
creating a very fair and transparent
process and when you've got a lack of
trust then you've got people who wonder
whether or not they should even be
involved at all whether or not they
should show up to the caucuses and the
primaries if the fix is already in yeah
and that that is sort of how it feels I
mean even this whole thing with
super-delegates that ultimately could
you know override what the what the
people voted for and the rest of it and
I don't know I know that there was a lot
of turnover from four years ago but I
don't know that they've done the
internal checks yeah you know there
there were a lot of people were
frustrated with what happened in 2016
who ran for you know those delegate
positions to sit on the Rules Committee
to try to bring about some of these
changes you know I've been calling for
an end to super-delegates
for a while now calling for open
primaries make it so that our system in
our primaries are open transparent and
actually representative of the votes
that people are casting we're not
anywhere close to where we need to be
they got rid of super-delegates just in
the first ballot ad at the convention
but if there is a challenge ballot as
you know given a crowded primary there
there
likely be then in the second and any
ongoing ballots super-delegates will
come into place so right so ultimately
the super Adela's delegates it still
could override the will of the PM which
is the whole problem with with that
whole super delegate system what do you
make just more broadly about just the
general process like when you're on
stage and you know you had that moment
that really caught fire when you were
really taking Kamala Harris to task on
some of the decisions she made related
to criminal justice reform and like that
caught fire and then it's like that you
have to just sort of do that that's a
catch and I think with these debates is
it's it's all about the media their
ratings and ultimately profits you know
media's money is that just us though
like I complain about the media you know
but you don't think it's just that all
of us sort of like I was like yeah
soundbite right but but when you when
you have the candidates who are on the
stage and you're given anywhere from 30
to 60 seconds to make your case to the
American people about any one of a
number of really important issues that
we're facing our voters really walking
away with a good sense of a depth of
understanding on an issue the clear
contrast between the positions that we
hold you know they're there maybe let's
say top ten things you would do to
reform immigration for example you don't
get to make those points and make those
differences when you've got these quick
little sound bites and the only thing
making news at the end of it the only
thing people are promoting or
remembering are those flashpoints are
those sound bites that the media
promotes and and and no I don't think
it's just us cuz I've been hearing from
folks who were seeing out in the Labor
Day parades and people were saying you
know gosh you did great at the debate
but I really want to hear more mm-hmm
you know really have an in-depth
conversation with candidates allow us to
be able to make make our case to share
our experience that positions we hold
the vision that we have for this country
in a meaningful way and voters aren't
getting that and and you know you see
some of them saying I'm just I don't I
don't have time for this I don't get
anything by spending two hours watching
that debate so that's the thing
somewhere right you don't feel more
educated right after and that's how
generally the mainstream media has been
treating us also
these debates end up being kind of
Asherah you know sure charade about this
is a providing a fair transparent
process for voters to become educated
but none of that's actually happening
yeah well I saw something that said that
you basically won the climate change
debate because you weren't in it but by
not being there yeah you know that that
oddly was enough do you think you'll be
able to get back in I mean do you think
you're gonna be able to make enough you
don't know I don't know we'll see
because it's not it's not about you know
are are we going to be able to get to
where we need to in the polls there are
27 polls that are out credible polls
that show that I've met the standards
set by the DNC but they've just chosen
not to recognize most of them if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell